Rumer Willis has spent a year getting a
lion removed from her arm and that is
one reason that so many people think
rumor must be the lion on the mask
singer you know this for sure a big
twist is happening tonight and Nicole
Scherzinger told us all about it this
week you're going to see alien lion
unicorn a rabbit take the stage they're
going to do an ensemble number and then
they will also each bring a physical
object to give us a clue on who they are
[Music]
they have no idea who each other is
[Music]
yeah it's like a Bella Hadid bug right
we've seen the alien Serb adapt and
tonight in this exclusive preview she
really has the panel stumped Oh coming
out did you have any idea the masked
singer would be such a phenomenon and be
life-changing for you no no not at all I
have no idea who this is
I don't know who I am I really don't
have a good reason to be out there I
don't I'm not a singer I'm not a
musician I'm pretty much is just like
you know the resident village idiot well
the cool is a singer the Pussycat Dolls
performer has that musical ear and she
admits she just can't figure out who's
behind the mask my biggest shock and I
think everyone's biggest shock was who
actually ends up winning the show more
good news for my favorite new show the
masked singer Fox just announced it has
been renewed for season two I have my
costume ready I won't tell anyone I
promise
put me on coach
[Music]
you